manufacturer to your condoms base
two percent of the time
probably I don't know he's about to
it's a question I'm seeking legal advice
in his mind right now
because the product didn't work right
yeah but then again she's still got the
choice whether or not she wants more
times the people we're having babies
it's because they're not using condoms
so even your argument doesn't matter
because you didn't have you didn't use a
condom you weren't using condoms
so it doesn't matter that's incorrect
okay
one off okay but you're telling me men
have multiple children and every single
child was the two percent like come no
that's not that's not what you're saying
I'll say I'll say one thing the story
you told about to go on the sa I
actually understand what you're saying
because I was in a similar situation but
I understand what you're saying however
more times that's not the situation and
people are just Reckless people are just
spreading their seat everywhere thinking
nothing's gonna happen there's
consequences to actions if you're
deciding to be sexually promiscuous as a
man there's consequences so take
precautions that's the point yeah but I
I get that well you don't because you're
arguing against it that's I'm not
arguing against it yeah yes you are what
have you been doing bro I am saying to
you you're sounding like you like the
sound of your own words
if someone understands what I'm listen
I'm saying to you guys this yeah
if I have sex with a woman and I have a
condom on it's not 100 right of course
it's not but it's about it sorry
it's not 100 right right we know it's
not 100 but okay let's go with that it's
100 yeah if I had sex with you that
means you don't have you don't have a
child okay
now
if I choose to have sex with you without
a condom does that mean I am saying that
I I am agreeing to have a child with you
you both are Reckless forget about
Reckless I'm gonna say you can't forget
about Reckless because you are being
Reckless and that's the thing that might
make you get a good practice so are you
being Reckless what do you mean
are you being Reckless yes
right if a girl is not requiring men to
put on a condom before if before they
have sex she is also being Reckless but
what I'm saying is if you keep getting
different [ __ ] pregnant the common
denominator is you yes if you keep
finding yourself in the same situation
you might be the problem
it's like future coming here just like
just like if the girl has multiple baby
daddies it might be her yeah exactly it
might be her it's like it's not a future
coming in saying it's not my fault I've
seen anything I don't agree I don't
because if okay you just want to argue
with exactly don't agree bro cause I
okay if I have casual sex casual oh my
God I do not want to have a kid I want
to have oh yeah
because two percent is a large
proportion of people
you said you said the small percentage
just doesn't matter and I'm saying two
percent of a large proportion of people
is a lot of people
a lot of men that have to go through
that
and there's no there's no recourse for
it it's just that you was irresponsible
they're not they're not there's no
recourse for what like I don't I just
don't understand what point you're
making like like I think I have casual
sex without being a girlfriend can we
can we agree that if you keep getting
women pregnant it might be your fault
right it might be your fault yes or no
okay can we agree that if you're a woman
that keeps getting pregnant for other
men and you have multiple baby for baby
fathers it might be your fool
can we agree that most men no that get
can we agree that most men that are
getting girls pregnant left and right
are not wearing contraception
most yes yes
okay
so we agree okay can I just say can I
just say one point
over two percent okay if you order two
percent and you've done everything right
in the condom still rips unfortunately
that's life
see now we're answering my question see
now we're getting that's my question now
you see now you're answering it and that
is fake bro
you just said you said you're like I'm
irresponsible if I don't use a condom
you are wait hold hold on but you're
irresponsible if I don't use a condom
but if I use one it's tough luck if it
breaks what else am I meant to say to
you
that are I'm sorry I'm sorry life is
hard because actions have come
consequences and if you if you don't
choose to get married some guys choose
to get married young so they don't have
to deal with this [ __ ] if you want to be
in the streets there's consequences for
being in the streets this isn't
controversial let me say something if
you if your condom breaks yeah you
better have good negotiation skills
that's what I'm saying I wasn't your you
know
just right with child and then you go
sleep with someone and then get them
pregnant on the first time
wrap your dick up or just be faithful to
your woman it's really not that hard
thank you
did we get any super chats
practice abstinence that's the best
reason if you will not have children
abstinence or just be careful man it's
not hard check who you have sex with and
do your part so that it mitigates the
the chance of that happening I'm glad we
feel there's so many men out black men
out here not having kids I hate when you
say oh black men have this problem it's
like no no I think none of my friends
have this problem well you know I think
we're done I think we found a female
chesca
I think we just found female Jessica
[Music]
there was just a misinterpretation of
what I meant I'm talking about the two
percent guys I'm not saying I'm not
saying that they're not the majority I'm
talking about the two percent guys yeah
where the condiments burst are we saying
that is tough luck for you lot even
though women have six different
contraceptions that they could use to
stop you even though you knew I just
wanted to have casual sex
tough luck do you know why it's stuff
like because you knew you knew all this
stuff for all these facts before you had
sex you knew that so that's why it's
tough luck because unfortunately you
took every precaution there's no nothing
you could do and it ripped that's life
do you drive luck I drive right not 90
I've never had an accident in my car
right but it's possible that I could
right so 99 of the time that I'm driving
on the road I don't have an accident if
I have an accident people say boy
she couldn't see that coming I never saw
it coming that person maybe never saw it
coming but it's part of life
so it it it actually [ __ ] what I say
[ __ ] happens bro okay so single parents
but the thing is but if I say oh
um I should I could say I'm never gonna
drive
I could stop driving and say the reason
people can ask me why do you don't you
drive because there's a two percent
chance I could have an accident and you
can still be hit by a car even if you
don't drive I mean I mean I I agree I
agree just not have sex bro you know
that two percent is there just like I
know the two percent of having an
accident is on the street I can say I'm
not gonna drive but I drive yeah also
also me personally I've never smoked my
life never done a drug other than other
than drink alcohol just like I've never
done anything like that but I could
still get cancer I can still get cancer
right it's life it's not basically it's
just casual sex and women could have
casual if that's if that's what you take
from it then fair enough don't protect
yourself so we established it then
protect yourself have as much
intercourse as you want ladies do
whatever you want as much as much as you
want you know what's crazy it makes
sense
like why do you why do you like this is
this is why I'm sorry you argue like a
girl because this is what girls do is
when they say I said things that I
didn't say I advocate all the time that
women shouldn't sleep around and now
you're just for no
who is allowed to sleep around anyone
that wants to sleep around is allowed to
sleep around yeah I'm just saying there
are consequences that go with it 100
that's that's my standpoint like you
know I mean you're allowed to do
whatever you want but it doesn't mean
you have to be doing it with me I figure
I mean okay so it's not foolproof you
know condoms aren't foolproof you are
choosing to have sex with another person
so what comes with that is also the
understanding that the other person can
make a decision that's going to impact
your life which is why you have to vet
the person why should you have the
responsibility because it's your life
let her engage go on why should why
should why should you why should you be
responsible
why why should the men be responsible
I'm saying you can take every precaution
but you still have to be mature enough
to understand that by having sex with
this person pregnancy is a possibility
yes right so if something does go wrong
you might have to live with that
consequence correct yes okay so know the
person you're sleeping with
don't don't have unprotected sex take
every precaution but if that happens and
the woman doesn't want to avoid it at
the end of the date you made that
decision you had ever you had so many
chances before you could have picked a
different woman there are so many other
things you could do instead of just
blaming the woman that doesn't want to
kill a baby like that I just don't
understand why also also I've clocked as
well there's so many goals sorry sorry
about it there's so many people who have
sex with girls who you can tell even if
she says she takes a pill you can tell
that
she's not exactly someone who keeps to a
schedule so she might miss a day or two
every now and then and you will still
have sex and be like oh she's linked
she's like let me just do it that's your
four you picked her you picked her you
can do everything you can you can use a
condom and still pull out and if you get
if she gets pregnant that's life